[Music]
would you like to see this actually
that's a rhetorical question we know you
do because Ironman 3 is the single most
requested sins video in the history of
cinema since you guys must have really
hated that movie but here's the thing
we're very busy and while we notice
plenty of sins in that movie we have
lots of other stuff to work on right now
bastard so we figured you want it so bad
you that's right
we're crowdsourcing this book you rent
the sins we'll pick the best ones and
stitch them together in the ultimate
everything wrong with video and then
we'll credit on-screen each user who
suggests the sin that ends up making the
final cut it's your turn to be the
nitpicking assholes
so don't hear the important details how
do you submit a sin for this incredible
crowdsource sins video easy just email
it to us at cinemasins at gmail.com make
sure you put iron man 3 submission as
your subject because we're literally
going to filter the email account by the
phrase Iron Man 3 submission so if you
don't put that phrase in your subject
we'll never see it then you'll hate us
for not using your suggested sin when
really you're the asshole for not
following directions I feel like an
asshole
don't forget the password
no I'm kidding there is no password
remember the more your sin falls in line
with the typical cinemasins tone and
style the more likely it is to be chosen
if you need some inspiration watch our
sins video in the original Iron Man with
such classic sins as the swingers joke
Avril is in Vegas but he's not picking
up beautiful babies The Big Lebowski and
the historical Marvel reference this is
what Stanley must have told Jack Kirby
and Steve did go back in the day or you
can watch our sins video on Iron Man 2
with such memorable sins as the gag
about the new actor playing roadie a
hush went over the crowd at Rody's
alarming weight loss in substantial
plastic surgery work since his last
public appearance The Simpsons reference
[Music]
and the bird bonus round or you can
watch our brand-new superhero movie
playlists of every single sins video
we've created for superhero based films
Iron Man 3 comes out on DVD and blu-ray
September 24 you have until October 1st
to get your sins in dust now we may
augment or tweak some submitted sins
where needed and will definitely add a
few of our own to keep things
interesting but this will be the first
everything wrong with video created by
the fans so don't miss your chance to be
a part of it now leave us the fuck alone
so we can get back to watching x-men I
mean men at luxury
I mean Cloud Atlas
p-nut